hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name hi I'm Paula Deen Paula
Deming is back when I first met Paula
she said she's a gamer and I was like
well when III rolls around and you're
coming by and she just got back from
Kansas I just got back from a wedding
and now we have collided here today and
just a few minutes ago the watchdog's
Legion gameplay trailer dropped so I
figured we should get into this Paula
you got to follow this woman on YouTube
and twitch
she has Let's Plays and covers gaming on
YouTube and she also streaming on Twitch
free gaming so Paula my gamer friend one
of the four I have let's get into this
shall we try to live up to the title of
your one
[Music]
that people surrounding cages like
animals
my goodness killer robots everywhere
it's like bad news it's up to us to take
our city back open your eyes take a look
around
[Music]
daddy the man if you get anyway
[Music]
folks wish to avoid squirrels the Dragon
Tattoo
[Music]
yes oh my gosh I love this
[Music]
[Music]
it looks so cool yay
watchdogs Legion available March 6 2020
hostage trailer we're gonna we're gonna
watch the gameplay walkthrough'
injustice what I really want to see how
the combat actually yeah I'm excited
about it based on the trailer but I want
to see actual gameplay I mean really
quick thoughts before we go into that I
mean this trailer invited me it was kind
of like watching a guy ritchie film like
Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels and
like snatch having a lot of like London
gangster sort of vibes but they're the
protagonists here because they're the
resistance against the evil militia
going on in London come on just like
shuffling over and then just like these
characters look like a lot of fun to
play they do they look really fun and
like they each have like a different
thing
yeah good at which I hope means you have
a lot of like variety and what you can
do based on who you're choosing to play
yeah see when we watch the gameplay but
this looks like a fun like sort of
open-world to play like as an online
game this is gonna be a whole lot of fun
to do because yeah the only tease like
what four characters here you got a guy
who's good with guns you got a better
knuckle boxer you got like it Elizabeth
Salander a character like you pointed
out and you got your old woman who seems
like a much more senior version of Helen
Mirren in the movie you're right
something like that that was cool yeah
let's watch this gameplay one
greatest city in the world all right a
city in the world used to be
government's fights off extremists are
grabbing power organized crime slicing
up the violence the wallbox are out the
freedoms are bloody junk but it sank
their London this is our London there's
a new power growing it's yeah oh here we
go so got sharp eyes peeled
yes I like this inch of humor really
does have that British wit man they
brought London alive I've never even
been there but this will be my way of
going everything just so getting games
now Bobby Jones are everywhere kicking
their [ __ ] teeth in lightly brilliant
never would have thought of that
find a recruit that can help against
major eyes amateur MMA fighters a skill
suit sure but we need a drum expert yeah
she's also Annika
this is so cool into adrenaline so you
can like scan people and see what
they're dealing with it's like half of
London is a resistance army home there
you go oh yeah he's already mainly
combat boots really
look like street-level realistic No
Surrender business oh cool
oh yeah there's old lady let's finish
what we started that's promising
what do we know he was killed I should
be able to predict his next move from
that data record I love that even taken
over suction
I love the distinguished dialog yes my
favorite orange yes I will never play as
anyone else
oh yes she should be the whole gameplay
oh my gosh see what she does the mystery
the trouble according to the Scotland
Yard Records
Jimmy sister was killed by plan Kelly
who believed he seeking his revenge
inside camden market environment all
sorts of it is if good has to be on
stables something fingers and toes
full lockdown just thought art just the
details in the environment visually and
I didn't really like it
the London booths have Wi-Fi spawn
oh nice
oh cool I mean rescue Jeanette camden
market all right Naomi
try not to get killed will be the rent
of the day that's a great way to sneak
around that so yeah
so we able to activate his oh nice I
love a good stealth kill it's so
satisfying don't destroy the cannabis
can you use the cannabis in the kick
Stables it's human trafficking Jimmy
again that chief it's a humor kisses a
lot of guns you got options too everyone
has distinguished fighting styles Satan
imagery in this game very tactical
she looks like the kind of character I
would like to play yeah because I really
enjoy like the stealth nah she was like
a military woman this the roving help oh
man she's awesome
oh bugger yeah
then again we showed those fast didn't
win we almost died out there tonight
look nice round for me but can handle
myself
right I don't think you think you're
better offer than you recovered there's
no one to trust
that's what they want me to think and
that's how they'll take us one at the
time it doesn't have to be that way
together we can change things wellhe
recruit or not what was that like well
he didn't make it
oh I know you can place him I didn't
play the other watchdog secretary laters
yeah okay now yeah now you have a new
character everyone has a reason to fight
and dedsec is open to anyone and welcome
to the resistance
[Music]
it's a lot of characters that walk
through 6:22 I did it so fast did such a
good job it made me excited about
playing this game yeah that looked great
I loved how I mean in terms of realizing
their characters everyone has their own
unique way I like of course they're all
British but they have their own unique
form of dialogue not everyone sounds the
same in terms of the the verbage use and
also like you're not just hop around
different looking characters they
mechanically work differently yeah they
sound they feel like different people
like they're saying because of the
dialogue but also because like they have
different fighting styles they're good
at different things and so I imagine
that you're like okay well we need to go
to this area of this mission to complete
which of these characters is going to be
the one that's going to be best to
choose for this thing and then you can
pop in and out of different people or
whatever feels best for your play style
and I it seems like that you're also
able to like recruit people along the
way before you know you're gonna have
all of London in the resistance and
there's gonna be no one to resist
against eventually because it looks like
it's gonna be primarily resistant and
then the people who are resisting
against will eventually become the
resistance because you will have
overpowered them because it seems like
no wants to be under this unfairly rule
but yeah I mean you had like the
street-level guy like even just the way
he fights feels like a dude who like
grew up on the London streets in the
poverty section and then going through
jack in a car which is really cool and
then you got the old lady hell in my
hero she's the best and then of course
you get like the tactile more like the
job way kind of maneuver around like I
said when we were watching but that
looks to me like just the way I like to
play games
that one looks yeah the kinds of things
I like doing in game exactly as you say
you're playing Last of Us right now yes
I am streaming in plugging Paul's
channel yeah come watch me play The Last
of Us I'm getting this mechanics in that
but well that involves a lot of sneaking
around and like my favorite games are
the Last of Us in Metal Gear Solid 3
those involve a lot of sneaking around a
lot of hand in hand combat a lot of
shooting so that's why the in terms of
playing yeah I'm there with you that
that third the third character is more
of my cup of tea
my boys carpet a watchdogs Legion sweep
your chimney all wheel all wheel they
need that character they need American
stereotyping why is anyone play is this
guy it's so annoying and also like the
environment realized too easily this
could have lent itself to feeling just
kind of like a doom and gloom desolate
world
she was so bright so bright and there's
there's a rhythm to it there's a there's
kind of this energy to it that makes you
want to have fun and explore it as
opposed to like Oh scary doom and gloom
danger everywhere cuz it could have
easily been that but it's not so I like
that it has a different kind of tone
than what most games or even like a
movie format would have normally lend
itself to and I think having some of
that British dialogue that British humor
has a lot of adds a little levity to it
yeah this looks great yeah I'm really
excited about it glad you could be here
Paolo well guys are you excited for
watchdogs Legion leave a comment down
below we're gonna cover a few more game
trailers while she's here subscribe to
the real rejects if you liked this video
hit the like button you know what
youtubers say notification bells click
it you don't have enough of those
clicked Paula you know where to follow
her like I mentioned at the top she's
just a part of the fan theory TV YouTube
channels a heads up I should probably
mention that's the Doctor Who which is
why I'm wearing my Doctor Who shirt
there you go fan Theory TV just type my
name in to youtube Paula Demi and you'll
find my channel thanks for watching